rené sébastien bauer merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors le
gouvernement a donc déclaré que la
situation était sous contrôle en
allemagne après un mois de restriction
dans la vie sociale comment cette
nouvelle at elle été reçue dans le pays
bon elle a été reçue avec un certain
scepticisme peuvent évidemment de côté
je crois qu'il n'y a pas de grandes
différences au niveau individuel avec la
france on se trouve dans une situation
tout à fait comparable la différence est
peut être que la distribution régionale
est différente et surtout et c'est un
peu un effet qu'aucun s'il ya à peine
six mois
une grande étude de la fondation
bertelsmann avait proposé de fermer 60%
des hôpitaux
heureusement qu'on ne l'a pas fait ce
qui explique un peu davantage de
l'allemagne par rapport aux autres
elle était en retard de la fermeture de
deux structures importantes d'un niveau
médical on ne l'a pas fait heureusement
mais à part ça la situation est à peu
près comparables celles de la france est
en moi avec des chiffres tout de même
qu'ils sont en deçà de ce qu'on peut on
peut voir en france elles sont en deçà
de ce qu'on peut voir en france mais en
allemagne comme en france il ne faut pas
voir le niveau national général il faut
voir le régions le niveau régional et
les très différents en allemagne comme
en france on ne peut pas comparer munich
et les régions rurales 2
la frontière tchèque comme on peut pas
comparer la glace avec helikos est ce
que l'allemagne était préparé à 7 à
cette pandémie selon vous est ce que le
gouvernement avait imaginé ce scénario
non il y avait il y avait évidemment
dans l'arrière front comme en france
aussi des spécialistes en épidémiologie
qui avait fait des études sur se pose
problème mais les je crois que
l'héritage de davie qui avait fait
beaucoup plus d'expérience dans ce genre
était mieux préparé que nous sommes
finalement l'allemagne était dans le
même pétrin que la france abat quoi
est-ce que vous attribuez cette
situation
du gouvernement est ce qu'il y avait
plus de matériel disponible néanmois il
y avait beaucoup plus de lits d'hôpitaux
disponibles et non seulement de lits
mais aussi de personnel capable de les
gérer
c'est on oublie toujours c'est pas le
nombre de deux respirateurs qui importe
c'est aussi le nombre de dettes
soignants de soignants qui sont capables
de les manipuler
c'est ça c'est un avantage de
l'allemagne mais pour le reste je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait une grande
différence c'est cdh un peu des hasards
de la distribution régionale
il ya le problème de la glace avec c'est
avec ces rencontres que religieuse qui
est qu'ils ont été un déclenchement
important il y a eu quand même le lait
les le fascisme et le carnaval en
rhénanie kiev jouer un peu mais le même
rôle mais moins important il faudra je
crois quand tout sera terminé faire une
analyse très judicieuse et tri presse
méticuleuse de tous les facteurs qui ont
engendré ce genre de tous deux
d'évolution il ya beaucoup de hasard
dans tout ça parce que dans la stratégie
choisie par l'allemagne
pas de stratégie d'immunité de gros pas
de confinement très restrictif au fond
ça a été les bonnes la bonne méthode
selon vous ce n'est pas tout à fait
exact confinement est quand même assez
ce très restrictif aussi il ya des
différences régionales la bavière agi
différemment que que le land de thuringe
avec raison puisque la bavière est
beaucoup plus touchée que le land de
thuringe
mais la situation est peut-être mois -
moins dangereuse que là pour la france
parce que elle et va se terminer plus
vite mais les restrictions ici à munich
était à peu près comparables celles de
la france on a eu on avait le droit de
quitter la maison pour aller se promener
d'accord mais c'est c'est pas paris on a
beaucoup de parcs on a posé beaucoup d'
espaces verts ou le dos rejet de ce qu
aux contaminés étaient assez restreint
et mais je crois je ne crois vraiment
pas que les différences de la décision
actuelle dans des différents
gouvernements soient vraiment
importantes ce qui fait la différence
fait les infrastructures qui étaient pré
existantes et qui était différente en
allemagne en france ou en italie
juste en amour pour conclure il nous
reste très peu de temps est ce que
l'allemagne se prépare à faire face à
une deuxième vague éventuelle de
l'épidémie on y pense on y pense oui et
tout du tout la levée des restrictions
actuelles effet sous caution de les
réintroduire des que les chiffres
deviennent plus intenses
merci beaucoup rené sebastian bauer je
rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste en
chirurgie générale et expertise médicale
merci à vous